[Music]  the nominees for Best Original Score are  the Curious Case of Benjamin Button by  Alejandra Destler defiance by James  Newton Howard milk by Danny Elfman  Slumdog Millionaire by a R Rahman wall-e  by Thomas Newman and the Oscar goes to  ar-rahman the Slumdog Millionaire  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  before coming  I was excited and terrified the last  time I felt like that was doing my  marriage there's this dialogue from the  Hindi film called Mary pass maha which  means I have nothing but I have a mother  some mother's here her blessings are  there with me I'm grateful for to have  come all the way and I want to thank the  Academy for being so kind all the jury  members I want to thank Sam Schwarz IDB  are all the crew of Slumdog mr. gosar  rocky bottom blase my musicians in  Chennai in Mumbai and I want to say  something in summer which says which I  normally say after every award which is  a la program a Dominic a god is great  thank you  [Applause]